[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends thank
you for joining in with us at this
program
i'd like to know this is a question and
answer program where you send us the
questions we do the research and we
answer them in so far as it is possible
i want to give you the address where you
can send your questions to us this is an
electronic address it'll be on this
on the screen
it's tv at some tv dot org tv at some tv
dot org we'll be glad to get your
questions
and make every effort to answer the
questions i have with me
pastor c.a murray
associate speaker here at secrets
unsealed
and it's always a delight to work with
you ca and i'm going to ask you to have
a word of prayer before we delve into
our questions you're glad to do so
shall we pray dear father we thank you
and we praise you for your word which is
a lamp unto our feet a light unto our
path we thank you for the power of your
word for the instruction that comes
through the study of your word for the
information the inspiration for the
direction it gives us as we seek to draw
closer to you and as each day brings us
closer to that day when you shall put in
your appearance to take your children
home
may we be prepared and may we fortify
ourselves even on this day
as we prepare for that glorious day
which we know is soon to come bless this
program bless the questions bless the
answers that we shall give from the word
of god and may christ be glorified may
he be seen and experienced again and
anew and we thank you dear father in
jesus name amen amen
you know there's a certain individual
that sends us questions and he sends us
a plethora of questions
and they're very good questions
but unfortunately we can't only answer
the questions of one particular
individual we'd love to be able to
answer all of them but
here is one
that this individual sent us
and i'm going to read the question and
then maybe see a you can
share
what you think is the answer to the
question
sdas claim that the prophecy of
revelation 10 was fulfilled in the
millerite great second advent movement
from 1840 to 1844. so could you describe
a little bit what happened uh
you know revelation 10 the little book
episode
uh revelation 10 talks about and tells
us about
the consuming of that little book
how that it would be in the mouth very
sweet
but
once being digested it would be very
bitter in the in the belly
our uh
spiritual forefathers saw the
fulfillment of this
in the 1844 the october 22 1844
experience
um
there was great excitement great joy
when it was thought that christ was
going to return
on october 22 1844
um
so the the consuming of that
understanding was very joyous because we
really thought it was going to be over i
say we are our forefathers the the
millerites uh adventist church wasn't
here quite then these were these were
millerites people who were looking for
the second coming of christ and of
course when he did not come when christ
did not put in his appearance it became
very bitter um we have many many
statements that it was our hopes were
blasted and it was a very very very
terrible terrible day so uh it bespeaks
that time when we uh mistakenly thought
i mean we knew something was going to
happen we got the time right we got the
event wrong
and
so revelation chapter 10 talks about
that time and pre-figures that time very
good explanation we needed that
explanation to finish asking the
question
revelation chapter 10 of course
describes the great advent movement and
the great disappointment
and then the chapter ends at verse 11
and it says and he said to me
you must prophesy again
too many peoples nations tongues and
kings
uh
the second part of the question is this
so seventh-day evidence claimed that
revelation 10 was fulfilled in the
millerite great second advent movement
1840 1844 but
they also claim
that the prophecy which follows in
revelation 11
was fulfilled or in or by the historical
events culminating in the french
revolution from
1789 he puts to 1794 but it's actually
1798 with the
the
pope taking prisoner yes
so so
why do we say that revelation 10 was
fulfilled
between 1840 and 1844
and then we see that revelation 11 is
fulfilled before that
1789-1798
shouldn't be consistent and think that
uh both chapters should be in
chronological order that's the big
question
excuse me
therein lies the key
um and you see this a little bit in
daniel also revelation
does not always
proceed in precise chronological order
many times you will see
an insert
or a pause or little parenthetical
insert in a flow which changes the
direction of that flow just a little bit
if you're going by chronological order
sometimes you'll miss things because the
book does not always follow follow that
way which is why
and you've said this many times we
really need to take our times and a time
and bite off revelation in manageable
bite-sized pieces because sometimes you
miss things or sometimes you insert
things that are not there
and if you're looking for pure
chronology pure chronological order it
doesn't always do that yeah yeah one of
the keys one of the important keys
to really understand the book of
revelation
is to understand its literary structure
yes in other words the order of events
transpires because it goes back and
forth
now in general terms this same
individual asked another question which
i'll address now
we say that the churches are repeated in
the seals and the seals are repeated in
the trumpets
but even within the series even within
the series of the seals and the trumpets
there are cycles
that break the chronological sequence
yes uh and uh and that that is true here
in revelation chapter 10 actually
revelation chapter 11 verse 1 should
really be the conclusion of chapter 10
uh because the the angel tells john you
must prophesy again about many people's
nations tongues and kings
and then you have the idea of the
judgment
which which actually uh begins in 1844
then i was given a read like a measuring
rod and the angel stood saying rise and
measure the temple of god that's the
heavenly temple by the way and measure
refers to judgment
measure the temple of god the altar and
those who worship there
so in other words uh you must prophesy
again and then you have what actually
happened in 1844 the beginning of the
heavenly pre-advent judgment yes
and then beginning with verse 2
you have a description of
papal supremacy it goes back to the year
and then it takes you in from verse 2
all the way to verse 10 up to verse 6.
you have a description of the 1260 years
so it's taken you from 1844 and verse 1.
it's taking you back to the year 538
through 1798 the period of papal
dominion
and then in verse 7 it describes the
french revolution at the end of the 1260
years uh you know when they finish their
testimony of the beast that it sends out
about the bible
yes war against them that is against the
bible which represents france
and so you have this back and forth uh
precisely in these cycles in the book of
revelation you cannot read
daniel or revelation in strict
chronological chronological sequence
you know daniel 7 is another example
there are four cycles in daniel 7 yes
where the same material is repeated four
times yes you can't read the chapter
chronological from verse one all the way
to verse 27 and say that everything's in
chronological order yeah and that's why
i mentioned you see it a little in
daniel and but it happens several times
in revelation uh but it does happen in
daniel also so when you're studying um i
think your point is well taken that
11-1 really is the capstone of of 10
uh verse 11. uh should be one more then
you stop but leave out the court so then
you're actually shifting the scene
and and moving into another phase so uh
it is very very true that if you try to
go in purely chronological order you
will confuse yourself because it's not
written that way and i could provide
many many other examples from the book
of revelation where you have this back
and forth
you know
maybe i can recommend a study note that
i did
for one of our
summits in past years
the name of it is the wise she'll
understand
and basically
those study notes
the entire purpose is to study
structural matters relating to daniel
and revelation
so i would recommend that people get a
copy of that from secrets unsealed i
think it's also available for free
download online
so the name once again is the wise shall
understand yeah this is a good question
because there are those who who have
i want to say tripped up over this
because they've tried to put it in
strictly chronological order and for
some reason a scratching has it just
doesn't work well because it wasn't
intended intended to right yeah okay i
think we've covered that one you know we
could say a lot more about that but
you know we do have lots of questions i
have a big pile of questions on my desk
i don't know how we're ever going to get
to them but the next question
says the following
what came first between the creation of
man
and the planting of the garden of eden
my question is based on genesis 2 verses
7 through 9.
genesis 1
verses
verses 11 and 12 and genesis 1 verses 26
and 27
because it looks like there is a
contradiction between the account of
creation in genesis 1
and genesis chapter 2.
if the garden of eden was planted after
man
then the tree of knowledge of good and
evil was formed after man was created
then how do we explain that sin existed
before the creation of man as we teach
as adventists and other believers
the bottom line gist of this question
is how
the creation account of genesis 1
relates to the details that we find in
genesis chapter 2. are we really dealing
with two
different creation stories
or is it one
story uh where you have in chapter two
an amplification of what's in chapter
one it is the latter
you know we've dealt with a question
it's not precisely like this but sort of
similar to this uh someone else has seen
this and and said
is there two accounts are we dealing
with two accounts no we're dealing with
one event looked at from two slightly
different angles and one angle giving us
a little more information and a little
more nuance dare i say than the other
but they are the same event
just spoken about and uh examined
slightly differently yeah and and you
know genesis chapter two
actually
uh the amplification begins with the
creation of vegetation on the third day
yes because it speaks of the tree of
knowledge of good and evil
then it refers to the creation of adam
from the dust of the ground
then it describes
then it describes the creation of the
woman
after that yes
and and then of course in chapter three
you have the
tree of knowledge of good and evil and
the test of the
loyalty of adam and eve to god
so so in genesis chapter two you have an
amplification of certain elements in
chapter one that were not explained in
chapter one yes for example in genesis 1
26 and 27
it simply says um
so god created man in his own image in
the image of god he created him male and
female he created them it doesn't say
how he created the male and how it
created the female yes it simply says he
created them male and female
the purpose of chapter two
is to tell us that god created the male
from the dust of the ground we get that
in two seconds then he created the woman
from the river of a man yes so chapter
two is amplifying and explaining
precisely the creation of man in chapter
one exactly the purpose of chapter one
is to give us the chronological order of
the days of creation the order in which
god created things
chapter two is given to amplify certain
aspects from the third through the six
days of creation well said well said
well said
you know we have another example in
genesis
in genesis chapter 10
and there's other examples in genesis as
well
and it brings us back to the same point
that we had before and that is that uh
you have cycles
in scripture everything is not in
strictly in chronological order chapter
2 takes you back
revelation 10 has what is known as the
as the table of nations
it has a description of all the nations
of the world
and chapter 11 describes
the tower of babel and how those nations
came into existence yes
so if you read chapter 10 and 11 in
chronological order you're going to say
how can you have the table of nations
before the nations were divided at babel
well the fact is that it gives you the
climax chapter 10
the list of all of the nations and then
chapter 11 says there was this tower of
babel episode and then they were
dispersed across the whole earth and you
have the nations that came from that
experience
pastor i think one of the things we can
say is this is one of the beauties of
bible study
uh
it is nice to read the bible and and
i've done this you try to cover the
bible in a year and you you zip through
it and you get it in a year but then it
is it is
better dare i say to
bite off small portions and stay with
them until you get the understanding and
to study the word of god not just read
to try to cover it but read for
understanding right
and you know there's
there's a devotional study of the bible
which is different
than
searching the scriptures
a devotional study is you know it's to
feed your soul yes
whereas a scrutinizing of the bible
looking at the at the language at the
words at the syntax the grammar the
historical context etc
to kind of
understand the original intent of the
text yes
that is a different type of study than
just the devotional study where you're
reading for example the promises of god
to be encouraged
um
there's an intense bible study where you
want to see what the original writers
intended in their own historical context
well said
very very true
okay well i hope that this is helpful um
uh chapter one summarizing is
a description of creation in
chronological order god created the
light god created the firmament god
created the vegetation god
placed the sun moon and stars in their
locations
god created the fish and the birds
god created man then he created woman
and then of course we're told that he
rested on the seventh day then chapter
two
takes you back
to describe that god planted a garden
and he played and then he created man
out of the dust of the ground placed him
in the garden
and then from the rib of the man he
created a woman
and then after created the woman he
performed the first marriage so
basically that's the gist
of it
now uh here's another um
interesting question
this has to do with a presentation that
i made
number 18
of spirits of devils in the state of the
dead series
and this is how it reads
in your presentation on the state of the
dead
uh and then he puts in parentheses
number 18 spirits of devils if i recall
exactly
you claim that the greek of matthew 24
24 b or the second half of the verse
is pointedly indicating that there is
merely an assumption that it can be true
that the elect can be deceived
but that is not the case in reality
i do not see how you are getting this
from the greek
as the greek if clause is not in any of
the four classes of the greek
conditional clauses it is not in any
greek mood but rather in an infinitive
form uh so basically the idea of the
question is he deals with a lot of
grammar that probably most people don't
understand this last part
but
how do we know that the elect are not
going to be deceived
well let's read the text
i'm in matthew 24 24.
for false christs and false prophets
will rise and show great signs and
wonders to deceive
if possible
even the elect
now what does that seem to say or what
does it say
they will deceive
if possible
even the elect
so if it says
i will deceive if possible
pastor boer
i am in effect saying
it is not possible to deceive pastor war
true or false right or wrong yeah
so the bible saying that the deception
if it were possible
would happen
but putting the if there says it is not
possible yeah yeah and and the emphasis
is that the deceptions are going to be
so so
overwhelming very true
that
you know
even the elect
although they're going to remain firm
they're going to remain faithful
they're so deceptive that
you know perhaps even the elect might be
deceived although they're not going to
really be deceived and how do we know
that they're not going to be deceived
well we go to the revelation
chapter 17 and verse 14
um
tells us about the elect or the chosen
ones
it says in revelation chapter 17
and verse 14 speaking about the kings of
the earth
allied with a beast and with a false
prophet
these will make war with that with the
lamb
and the lamb will overcome them
for he is the lord of lords and with him
are
those that are with him are called
chosen and chosen
full that is the elect chosen and
faithful
so clearly the chosen are not going to
be deceived because there are going to
be some that will be with jesus of
course they're known as the 144
thousands faithful ones the upshot is is
this my pastor my friend
that
these deceptions are going to be so
strong that if you are a half-hearted
student
if you are a person who is
half-converted or who is not
thoroughly
fortified dare i say
by the word by the presence by the of
the holy spirit you will be deceived
right uh the the very elect
are going to be rattled they're going to
be challenged but they won't be deceived
right so if you're
there's a term we used to use half
stepping
uh if you're half stepping you're going
to fall you're going to be deceived
because you have not fortified yourself
it's a call for fortification uh for the
people of god right
and it's important to notice the context
in which matthew 24 verse 24 is found
the context is
the counterfeit second coming of christ
yes
satan is going to counterfeit the second
coming of christ
ellen white calls it the almost over
mastering delusion it's interesting that
she uses the word almost
and she says clearly there in great
controversy that the elect will not be
deceived
and she gives a reason why they will not
be deceived actually there's two reasons
why the elect will not be deceived
she says the first reason why they won't
be deceived
is because
this false christ
is going to be walking all over the
earth
and he's going to be performing miracles
his face is going to be shining like the
sun
he's going to speak some of the
beautiful words that jesus spoke with a
sweet tone
and the great majority of the world are
going to buy into the idea that this is
the second coming of christ
but the elect
ellen white states will not be deceived
and then she explains why it's because
the bible tells us that when jesus
returns he is going to remain in the
clouds yes he's not going to come down
he's not going to touch the earth
so
this false christ which is satan
disguised as christ
is walking all over the earth the saints
they say we've studied the bible and the
bible tells us that he's not going to
come and he's going to touch the earth
yes the second thing that ellen white
mentions is
that this false christ who is satan
disguised as christ
is going to tell all of the inhabitants
of the world
that
sunday is the day we're supposed to keep
and that all the calamities in the world
are due to the desecration of sunday
the elect once again will say now wait a
minute yeah the bible says the seventh
day is the sabbath it doesn't say that
sunday is the sabbath it says the
seventh day is the sabbath in fact all
of these calamities came
because sabbath is not kept yes so for
two biblical reasons one this false
christ
is walking on the earth and the bible
says that jesus will remain in the
clouds and will be caught up
secondly this false christ which is
satan disguised as christ is going to
say that sunday's the day we're supposed
to keep
that contradicts the bible yes so those
who have studied the scriptures the
elect will not be deceived yes and this
is more than an illusion if you look at
verse 23 then if anyone says to you look
here is a christ or there do not believe
it well the reason that's in there is
because it's happening it has happened
is happening there there are people who
now have been proclaimed as christ
walking the earth um
it it's
for for
those of us who study the word of god we
know right away dismiss that because
it's not of the lord so it's it's going
to happen it is going to happen and
they're going to show
as the word of god says great signs and
wonders there are some people who are
very very impressed by signs and wonders
and we know we're coming to a time when
you cannot even believe your own eyes
you've got to believe the word of god
even though your senses may be telling
you something different yeah
uh verse 27
uh has the the point that i made
that the righteous are not going to be
deceived the elect are not going to be
deceived
by the manner the the false manner in
which satan comes it says in verse 27
for as the lightning comes from the east
and flashes to the west
so also will the coming of the son of
man be amen amen and so the second
coming of christ you know when you have
lightning shining from
east to west
it's not touching the earth is it it's
something you're seeing in the sky now
if it was coming from north to south
that is from up down
then you might say that jesus was going
to walk on the earth but it says that he
is go that as the lightning comes from
the east and flashes to the west so also
will the coming of the son of man be and
so the second coming is going to be like
lightning
jesus is going to remain in the air he's
not going to touch the earth you know we
think about this and i know our time is
getting away from us you think about all
of those who have come with messianic
aspirations uh who have led people
astray and how many people have died
from your jim jones to your david
koresha's uh to this fellow that with
the hail bach you know there have been
many who have done this and many have
lost their lives because they haven't
followed the word they haven't studied
the word
and they've listened to a man or men
as opposed to the word of god and paid
for it with their lives it's very sad
really you know these are
anti-little antichrists
for the antichrist
because it's interesting in matthew
chapter 24
in verse 23
it says then if anyone says to you look
here is
the christ not christ's yes you know but
the christ
or there
do not believe it
for false christs and false prophets
will rise show great signs and wonder to
receive if possible
even the elect and then jesus warns see
i have told you
beforehand yes yes yes and then and then
verse 26 amplifies therefore if they say
to you look
he is in the desert this is a single
antichrist he is in the desert do not go
out
or look
he is in the inner rooms do not
believe it
and so
you know if this majestic being is being
broadcast on television channels we turn
away from the television channels we say
it is not christ
well you know uh we covered several
questions and i guess now we it's time
to come to an end because our time is
just about up any final words before you
conclude the program ca the bible tells
us study this show thyself approve
never
has that been more apropos and
appropriate than these last days amen
just prior to the second coming of our
lord amen
well
run with it
again it is our pleasure to study the
word of god with you uh join us again
we'll be back you come back for i'd like
to know
[Music]
you